Ever wonder what a live-action Troy
McClure movie would have looked like?
How about Mrs. Doubtfire 2?
Keep your eyes on the screen
to learn about these cool projects — and
others — that nearly got the greenlight.
Phil Hartman had a superpower: He could
make anything funny. Take, for instance,
Troy McClure — his iconic role in The Simpsons.
You might remember this character from the
Planet of the Apes musical he starred in,
the clip shows he hosted, or the
infomercials he attached his name to.
"Hi, I'm Troy McClure. You may remember me
from such nature films as Ear Wigs Ewww.
And Man vs. Nature, the road to victory."
Do any of those sound hilarious in concept? Not so much. Are they gut-bustingly funny
when depicted by Phil Hartman? Absolutely.
Before Hartman was murdered, he was part of
early talks for a live-action Troy McClure film.
Most accounts indicate that Hartman
himself pushed the idea and that many
Simpsons staff writers were on board,
including Matt Groening. Tragically,
Hartman was killed by his wife
before any of this could take place.
Groening had flirted with the idea of
a live-action Simpsons spinoff before:
In 1994, he and Michael Weithorn completed a
pilot script for a show that focused on Krusty
the Clown. It never got off the ground, but
thankfully this was not due to anyone's death.
Following his trial for child molestation in 2005,
Michael Jackson spent the next few years away
from the spotlight. He slowly rehabilitated his
image, but also desperately needed
money. As such, in March of 2009,
he announced This Is It — a year-long residency
at the O2 Arena in London starting that July.
"When I say this is it, it
really means this is it."
Less than a month before the first show,
however, Jackson died of acute propofol and
benzodiazepine intoxication at the age of 50.
AEG Live, who promoted the concert, decided
to make some money off the event anyway.
They put together a documentary-concert
film titled Michael Jackson's This Is It,
which was released theatrically in October
2009. While some fans were dismayed by what
they saw as shameless profiteering, they were
massively outnumbered by those who saw the film,
which made $261 million worldwide. The
documentary was surprisingly low-key,
limited by the fact that its footage is
entirely from rehearsals. In the wake
of Jackson's shocking death, however, that
was more than enough to make it into a hit.
Sam Kinison was killed near the peak of
his popularity by a drunk driver. This
sudden and tragic loss sent shockwaves through
the comedy world. He left behind a series of
classic stand-up albums, TV guest spots, and music
video appearances. He also had several projects
lined up that were ultimately canceled,
including one with Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Bill Kinison, Sam's brother and business
manager, revealed in 2009 that the comedian
had signed a deal with New Line Cinema for
three movies shortly before his death. One
would have been a straightforward concert film,
one would have been a movie with Rick Moranis,
and one would have been a truly star-studded
affair. Of this last film, Bill Kinison shared:
"It was going to be Schwarzenegger,
Beverly D'Angelo, Christina Applegate,
and Corey Feldman [...] The movie was about
Sam as a convict, and it's an adopt-a-convict
thing [...] he comes and lives with you to help
him straighten out his life, and all that."
Alas, it was not to be — the movie
was shelved following Kinison's death.
The death of Robin Williams shocked the world.
The comic giant left behind a stunning legacy,
as well as four in-production films
that were eventually released.
There was, however, one project that went
unfinished: The sequel to Mrs. Doubtfire.
"Hellooooooo!"
Attempts at a Mrs. Doubtfire sequel date back
to at least 2001. Both Robin Williams and Chris
Columbus repeatedly turned down scripts
they found uninspiring. As Williams said,
Mrs. Doubtfire being unmasked in the original
movie made a repeat performance difficult,
but a sequel was finally announced in
April of 2014. Williams was set to star,
Columbus was signed on to direct, and Elf
screenwriter David Berenbaum would script
it. Of course, Williams' 2014
death put an end to the movie.
Training Day, a TV sequel to the 2001
Denzel Washington film of the same name,
was set to become a headlining CBS series.
"I'm the police!"
Bill Paxton starred as Detective Frank Roarke,
alongside Justin Cornwell as Officer Kyle
Craig. Just a few weeks after the series'
premiere, however, Paxton died of a stroke
following open-heart surgery. He was 61.
Paxton had shot all 13 episodes of Training
Day's first season prior to his death,
allowing it to air as planned. The show
saw a small ratings spike after he died,
but reviews weren't spectacular and its
audience dwindled as the weeks wore on.
Between low ratings, lackluster reviews,
and the death of the show's biggest star,
CBS chose not to recast the Roarke role
and pulled the plug after one season.
Hollywood spent much of the 1980s and the
1990s trying to bring Mordecai Richler's novel,
The Incomparable Atuk, to the silver screen. A
fish-out-of-water story about a Canadian Inuit
adapting to life in the big city,
the screenplay — simply titled Atuk –
went through many stars. So many, in fact,
that it is now believed to be cursed.
John Belushi was the first star attached to the
role and was by some accounts who screenwriter
Tom Caroll had in mind when writing the script.
Belushi's death in 1982 put an end to that.
Years later, producers reached out
to John Candy, who was interested
but died while still studying the script.
Overtures were made to Chris Farley, though
he too died shortly after expressing interest.
To this day, the film has never been made.
While his death didn't cancel the project,
it is also worth noting that Sam Kinison
was cast in 1988 and actually shot a scene.
He later took issue with the script and left,
resulting in a breach of contract lawsuit.
He died young as well — whether or not
the curse claimed him is up to you.
River Phoenix died in the middle of
shooting the American-Dutch thriller
Dark Blood, leaving the project canceled and
unfinished. That might have been the end of
it for most films, but director
George Sluizer had other plans.
In 2011 — 18 years after Phoenix's 1993 death
— Sluizer revealed that he still had the Dark
Blood footage. Worried that his work would be
destroyed, Sluizer swiped the negative from the
insurance company that was threatening
to destroy it to avoid storage costs.
From there, he re-edited the footage into
something approaching a finished film.
Sluizer announced that he had stayed in touch
with the Phoenix family and that he planned to
ask Joaquin Phoenix if he'd be willing to
redub some of River's lines. In response,
the entire Phoenix family made their disinterest
explicitly clear: They wanted no part of this.
Somehow, Sluizer still did it, and Dark Blood
premiered at the 2012 Netherlands Film Festival.
Chris Farley's public persona as brash and
goofy was at odds with his true self: A gentle
man self-conscious about his size and unhappy
with being typecast. Not long before he died,
he was hard at work on a biopic about silent movie
star Roscoe "Fatty" Arbuckle. The project had
promise and could have expanded his career beyond
clowning — but it wasn't completed before he died.
Arbuckle was one of the first true Hollywood
stars. He was a gifted physical comedian
and remarkably agile for his size, but he was
privately insecure and resentful of his girth.
Arbuckle is best remembered today for
being accused of the rape and murder
of silent film star Virginia Rappe. He was
exonerated after three trials — so much so
that the jury of the last trial apologized to
him. Regardless, his career was effectively over.
Farley knew this role could change his career.
His obsession with the movie endured through
the haze of his addictions — to the point
that some colleagues believed it to be an
unhealthy fixation. Ultimately, he never got
clean and died of a drug overdose in 1997.
John Kennedy Toole's A Confederacy of Dunces
is an iconic work of American literature.
As such, attempts to adapt it to the screen are
many — yet none of them have come to fruition.
John Belushi was the first
actor cast in the lead role
of Ignatius J. Reilly. A day or two before
he was supposed to finalize his involvement,
he died of a drug overdose. Years later,
another attempt at adapting Dunces was made.
John Candy was courted for the lead role
until he too passed away. Ditto Chris Farley,
who was considered for the role of Ignatius until
his 1997 death brought talks to an abrupt end.
Natalie Wood's enigmatic death by drowning
is a landmark Hollywood tragedy. She didn't
just leave behind an enduring mystery — she
also left behind at least two projects that
went unfinished. A few weeks after she died,
actor Timothy Hutton said that he and Wood had
purchased the film rights to Barbara Wersba's
book Country of the Heart. The book tells the
story of a teenage writer who falls in love
with a famous novelist dying of cancer. Her
death stopped the project before it could ever
start. The novel has since faded into obscurity.
Wood was also a few months out from making her
stage debut. She was working on Anastasia — a
play about the tragic Russian princess — set to
debut at the Ahmanson Theatre in Los Angeles. Tony
winner Arvin Brown was attached to direct, with
rehearsals to start in January 1982 and opening
night scheduled for the following February.
Development of the show ended upon her death.